North Carolina families live in
these particular homes but like
homes in every state they are the
expression of a love the love that
men and women feel for each other and for
their children the Stewart family happens
to live in this home and like most other
families they are held together by love
but like other loving parents mr. and mrs.
Stewart can be quite angry on occasion will
you look at that I've told her once I told
her a hundred times she will not put her
things away oh no not misleading late now
Ellen you can't expect her to run upstairs
with her stuff every time she comes in the
house I tell you is nothing but temper and
tantrums and salt all over it by the time she
was six now she's 15 it's starting all over
again oh let's not go through all that again
can't we have any peace and quiet around here
anymore oh yeah take her side you were in that
school counselor mrs. Soames now you know very
well that mrs. Soames is supposed to advise
the boys and girls at school that's her job
mrs. doe says I should go
out for the Dramatic Society
this is dumb said I might make a great actor
I could have been an actress anybody could
do you think she'll talk to me about it
oh no I'm just left out of everything
what do you want a pimp where is she now she
said she was going to a party at Glenda Ford's
you shouldn't have done it golly soon what's
the matter you sound like the angel Gabriel
hog hog oh geez no matter what anybody
says there's nothing wrong about a kiss
thanks for bringing me home Pete I had a swell
time - well time to come
father mother this is pink
I'm afraid it's all my fault mr. Stewart I'm
afraid it is this might improve matters if
you went home sorry Susan I'll be seeing you
nice boy I know you did everything you could
to embarrass me I don't think Mike one who
brings you a home at this hour of night is
this the kind of advice mrs. Soames gives you
Pete Bolton is my friend you know we only want
what's best for you Susan Susan where were
you where I told you I'd be at blended oh
no you weren't not after 11 o'clock I know I
called Glenda you called her yes I did we had
to Susan we were so worried I'm not going to
be spied upon you make a fool of me in front
of my friends I'm not doing anything wrong and
I have a right to lead my own life I might as
well be dead for all anyone cares I tried every
other kid has a good time nobody picks on them
every other girl has better clothes than mom
I'll do something wonderful like finding a million
dollars for becoming a modern
Florence Nightingale then look out
bring so ugly tonight might join
the Foreign Service like Mata Hari
you're old Susan Stewart yes Jen like an alligator
you're a woman of mystery you have all
the allure of the Orient who are you
you're a beautiful actress the beautiful
actress in the whole world and I love you
goodnight
you don't don't me divine cardigan I've seen
in years Bassett's it go new shipment that's
a pretty ribbon too but I think of Carl would
it look prettier in my hair hey it looks like
Mack Martin's got himself a new day yikes
look at those clothes she's in my Dramatic
Society she always dresses like that maybe
that's what her mother wants you to wear
don't talk about mothers to me why can't they
grow up like the restaurant they don't get out
much hey Pete you hearin Jim hammers old man's
making him work in the Stewart I paid for that
fender he'll be there for life Harry well
my pops giving me fits one day it's grew
up and be a man and the next day you're
out too late here comes your friend iMac
that's my part in the play no it is you're
going to play Katie hey woman
well goodbye now see you later
they can't do this to me I'm gonna go tell
mrs. stone it was my part in the play I was
just right for it he's as old as my mother I'll
show them I'll resign from the Dramatic Society
hey take it easy oh you're just like all the
rest but I'll resign just you wait and see
rob kill myself first Susan and what gives
with her who knows women come on sit down
not at all Glenda now I'm not trying to check
up on Susan the way she thinks I just wondered
whether you'd happen to see her if she said where
she was going oh she said she was going to see
mrs. Soames well then that's probably where
she is no then I'm of course I won't worry
Thank You Glenda and bye-bye that's gnomes woman
again doesn't she know we expect that child home
in time for dinner I have a good mind to go over
there and tell her exactly what I think why don't
you know I didn't mean exactly that naturally
I'm worried about Susan and so are you and it
does see why don't you go and see her then now
don't go on insisting on my going why not she
may have some advice for us all right then
I can wait and you're coming with me she's
your daughter too you know what why does it
have to be me Brighton's me not getting the
part frightens me I must be a dreadful person
no you're not dreadful don't try to tell me
that I know I'm not a very low you are you know
you are but I've seen enough young people after
years of teaching to know that you're not
a bit different from the rest of your crowd
why am i lonely you're not alone your
classmates have the same sense of of
being at see childhood is an island
you've left that behind on the edge
of the sea is a mainland you'll
be grown up when you reach it
only see you're travelling grown-ups can sometimes
seem pretty obstinate and trying mothers and
fathers sometimes have problems worries you may
not know anything about sometimes parents can
seem awfully unreasonable it's hard for them to
change easier for you you're younger will you try
to to understand them as people Susan to give in a
little here and there I will if you say so I trust
you mrs. stone if only I had a oh darn I should
I go it is a pleasure come in won't you thank you
I've wanted to talk to you about Susan mrs. Soames
I guess I waited long enough I'd liked it so then
why don't you run along with your father that's
a good idea I don't want you I sure you don't
it's awfully nice of you to see his missus own the
pleasure do it hope we're not intruding dawn dawn
good night dear good night good night mr. Stewart
won't you sit down mrs. Dewart absolutely ruin
everything the time that conversation is over may
as well leave town the kiyose thing you could have
let her do why did you I thought it was a good
idea currently who wants to have their friends
dragged into a family argument Susan maybe your
mother knows best why why does it just naturally
have to be the parents know best we're trying
Susan that's why your mother went to mrs. Soames
why can't you see things my way I'm afraid
you don't know what it's like to live with
Susan day after day mrs. Soames and that's
true enough although we do see a great deal
of her at school just does what ever comes into
our mind we think you're quite a good one mind
if a 15 year old when do you want her to start
using it this 15 year old mine when she's 18 or
24 surely you don't want that mrs. Stewart No
cream and sugar okay so I have a little cream
their dissatisfactions or her strength got to
think with the mind she has mrs. joy you and
I we must never be guilty of holding life back
though I couldn't share her life anymore she's
never at home when she is she's so irritable and
contrary why don't worry about him you just do
it they all have to go through it this period of
struggle uncertainty revolt that's how they grow
up to become independent people trust Susan
she can handle freedom because you've given
her a good foundation of sound values tell me
what's happened between me and my daughter she
needs her friends and her gang they all do
she needs DOS and Boyd you wouldn't want to
have her unattractive ignored oh I know it's
a difficult period she's hard-headed disagrees
with you about everything wants to run life
on her own turn just now she's kicking over
some of the traces but never was there a
time when she needed you more we can help
we can only remember to keep hands off if we
don't declare war on them we can only remember
that underneath it all there's someone too
certain about everything make you your friend
giver about three more years in which to
grow you're going to be very proud of it I
don't know what's gotten into you you
never used to pick on me Oh baby you
mustn't feel that way baby I don't want to
be coddled oh I want to be understood sure
sure you do Susan we all want to be
understood even your mother I'll try
I'll try real hard Susie
mrs. thumbs told me about the part Susan
I'm sorry you didn't get the one you wanted
I thought you know that white lace dress
of mine well mrs. Soames and I thought it
would be just perfect for your secondary
that is if you think it's right Robin
no it's hanging in the closet in my hall and don't
say brother hey looks as if
you made out all right yeah
you know she's 11 in a class of 46 Susan
C that's fine I can remember now a little
more of what it was like she's going through a
very difficult period yes and we've got to give
her a lot of understanding we've got to shore
make her really know that we love her it's just
perfect for me right to the part Oh mom you're
wonderful I feel as though I've lost you Oh mom
don't be silly it's not bad not bad at all
I wonder if Peter liked it well no it's not
supposed to be Boise well I like that he loved
it on mother we've tried to take the fun I'll
do and don't bother your father when he wants
to read turn around go over here I want to see
some people you know I was wondering if
we let it up in the front and down in
the back maybe it wouldn't wake up them
looks pretty good to me just the way it
is well it looks as if you girls are
gonna work things out alright for now
no the trials of adolescents aren't settled in one
day they must be lived through day after day year
after year parents are dismayed by rebellion
strangely mixed with the need for guidance and
support adolescents are more fide by inner and
outer forces urging them toward maturity while
holding them back and for both generations
the only answers are love and understanding